We have seen the amazing property of carbon
to form so many bonds with a
variety of other elements and even with other
carbon atoms. Its capability to
form so many bonds is what makes carbon widely
present. However, the living
world is dominated by one major combination.
What do we mean by this?
Well, although carbon forms numerous bonds
with several elements, the most
preferred element for combination is HYDROGEN!
Yes! Hydrogen and Carbon
readily form bonds to form a vast range of
compounds. Any idea what the
combination is called? These are collectively
called as Hydrocarbons. As the
name says, they’re compounds chiefly containing
Hydrogen and Carbon. So are
these compounds only made up of these two
elements?
Not necessarily! Hydrocarbons mainly have
these two. However, the other
elements like oxygen, nitrogen, sulphur and
many others also participate in the
formation of hydrocarbons. But the backbone
consists of carbon and hydrogen
atoms.
So a hydrocarbon will chiefly have carbon
atoms bonded to each other and
hydrogen atoms attached to them. They would
appear somewhat like this!
Wait a second… these are the saturated and
unsaturated compounds of
carbon right? Absolutely!
That is why they are referred to as the SATURATED
hydrocarbons, those with a
single covalent bond between all the carbon
atoms. We can see that all these
are single covalent bonds here.
And the others are called as UNSATURATED hydrocarbons,
that is those having
at least one double or triple covalent bonds
between the carbon atoms. Here
we can see one double covalent bond between
two carbon atoms! Hence
unsaturated.
Now in order to simplify our understanding
and to study these hydrocarbons in
detail, we divide these into three major categories.
These are called the Alkanes, Alkenes and
Alkynes.
Let us understand each type in detail. The
first one is Alkanes. This family is
that of SATURATED HYDROCARBONS. That means
all the carbon atoms share
a single covalent bond with each other. Now
can you tell me the maximum
number of carbon atoms that can be present
in alkanes? Well, we cannot
estimate it because the carbon chains can
be too long to count. So how do we
study the higher alkanes? I mean the alkanes
which have a very high number
of carbon atoms? Well, in order to study the
alkanes collectively, we have a
formula to represent them.
The formula for alkanes is C n H 2n+2 . In
this “n” will be the number of carbon
atoms. So can we represent all the alkanes
using this formula? Absolutely!
Let’s try it out.
C n H 2n+2
n  Number of carbon atoms
The simplest alkane that we know is methane.
Can you tell me its molecular
structure? Yes! It’s somewhat like this.
So here, we have one carbon and four hydrogen
atoms. Its formula is C H four.
Methane  CH 4
It’s an alkane with one carbon atom! Now
let’s see if this fits into the formula
for Alkanes!
What will the value of ‘n’ be here? ‘n’
as we know is the number of carbon
atoms! It’ll be one! Let us substitute the
value of ‘n’ in the formula.
The formula is C n H 2n+2 . The number of
carbon atoms present is ‘n’. It’s one!
What about the number of hydrogen atoms then?
It’s ‘two times n’ plus two.
On solving it further, we get the answer as
4. It’s the number of hydrogen
atoms! So in methane, we have one carbon atom
and four hydrogen atoms.
Does that give us CH 4 ? Yes! That is the
formula for methane. The formula
worked fine for methane!
C n H 2n+2
Number of carbon atoms = n = 1
Number of hydrogen atoms = 2n + 2 = (2 x 1)
+ 2 = 2 + 2 = 4
Methane  CH 4
This is how all the alkanes can be generally
represented with the simple
formula C n H 2n+2 .
Look at the formula! Do you notice something?
To get the formula of an
Alkane, all we need is the value of ‘n’.
So we can easily find out the chemical
formula of the alkane when we know how many
carbon atoms make up the
chain!
Let us try this out as well. We know that
the alkane with two carbon atoms is
ethane. Two carbon atoms means the value of
“n” in the formula will be 2!
What about the number of hydrogen atoms?
The number of hydrogen atoms is ‘2 times
n’ plus 2. That’ll be ‘two times two’
plus two. That is six hydrogen atoms. Thus,
the chemical formula of ethane
will be C 2 H 6 .
C n H 2n+2
Number of carbon atoms = n = 2
Number of hydrogen atoms = 2n + 2 = (2 x 2)
+ 2 = 4 + 2 = 6
Ethane  C 2 H 6
This is how all Alkanes can be represented.
Now let us talk about the next category of
hydrocarbons in the unsaturated
type category. We will talk about Alkenes
in the next video!